alors donc le mec se lève le matin il va
dans la salle de bain ils constatent que
le robinet fuit il va de sa femme elle
dort encore il fait ça et 18 mois et dit
pourquoi ça fait encore l du [ __ ] et elle
dit fait le idou je suis plombier dit je
travaille comme une bête il dit appelle
le plombier il ya elle répare l'a dit
[ __ ] c'est pas compliqué mais d'ici
comme le gazon là il n'est pas tendu il
dit elle dit elle dit mais fait le et 10
d'où je suis jardinier et dit je
travaille appelle le jardinet mme lemay
30 le soir le gazon tondu nickel il va
leur salle de bain le robinet fuit fais
à ma femme il dans la journée qui a fait
venir et le plombier le jardinier
devinant maurice à côté lui les gentils
je lui ai dit à mon gazon il est trop il
ya ma robinetterie elle marche pas il
l'a dit d'accord je te fais tourner qui
vous fait une gâterie ou alors tu me
fais un bon gâteau il dit alors tu dois
fait le bon gâteau elle fait d'où je
suis pâtissier
donc jamais quand dans un bar il faut
qu'on soit le patron et vers le bas il
fait si vous prenez un whisky le mec lui
c'est un whisky le clip bois louise
pièce bas patron il fait monsieur il
fait oui mais il faut payer 10 balles
pourquoi et libé ce que vous avez pris
un risque et dinan monsieur vous me
l'avait offert d'y commencer à vous de
faire ce qu'il va dire oui vous me dis
qu'est-ce que vous prenez moi quand je
dis à quelqu'un qui est ce que vous
prenez c'est que j'invite mes gars moi
je fais pas gaffe aux formulations
libéré mais c'est important monsieur
voilà moi j'ai cru que c'était à faire
si un jour être autre chose libre on bat
hockey bien le mec s'en va le lendemain
il revient donc le patron le voile
reconnaît là dedans que ça dit rien le
mec va au bar pour 1,9 casse l'oeuf et
nous avait un couteau pas trop lui je
vous ai rien dit que fait la demande est
ce que vous avez un couteau j'ai un
couteau il prend le couteau ils enlèvent
évidemment les locaux qui il commence à
couper l'oeuf en petits carrés
mais si vous faites là mais dit je
prépare mes zapa pour la pêche y pour la
pêche et du bail il y attache à 9 me dis
c'est que ces conneries les quarante ans
que je pêche jamais entendu parler de
pêche à l'oeuf à ava ient vous passez à
côté d'un truc énorme et y voyez le
petit bout des flammes le petit carré
vous le mettez au bout de l'hameçon vous
jeter ça un peu loin du bord et alors la
veille avec ça qu'est-ce que vous prenez
et ben oui ce qu'est
c'est un type qui se balade dans la rue
à bruxelles et qui y voit un type romney
deux chiens donc ils l'accueillent s'il
excusez moi monsieur de vous déranger la
dame arc à l'antenne
lacoste tient lourdeur
vous avez deux chiens absolument
magnifique du oui c'est vrai dit se
touchèrent là sont supers edit alors il
dit oui mais parce que healy j'ai
toujours aimé ccja sais quelle race un
édit voulez vous cher monsieur celui ci
est un labrador wideload sur wii l'autre
aussi
et il dit alors c'est ça coûte cher à
l'achat parce que ma femme a toujours
rêvé d'avoir de la voiture et du saumon
par les pas de celui ci m'a coûté une
petite fortune c'est l'autre fruits
l'autre aussi
ça mange beaucoup dur alors ça ça dévore
celui ci me dévore dévore dédié l'autre
oui l'autre au civil qu'elle diffuse et
moi pourquoi chaque fois que je vous
pose une question vite celui là est
l'autre aussi a dit excusez moi cher
monsieur c'est très simple parce que le
chien là est à moi et dieu l'autre et
oui l'autre ça
rime ses deux copains qui se rencontrent
irna qui dit à l'autre tu vas bien le
dif est extrêmement bien et 10 dans deux
mois je suis milliardaire je faisais
avant mais pourquoi pas 10 parce que
j'ai inventé un procédé révolutionnaire
et euh
là le monde entier est en train de se
l'arracher c'est à la fois écolo c'est
fait c'est vraiment de l'entreprise 2.0
moussavi avant midi c'est quoi il dit
j'ai trouvé le moyen de transformer la
merde amber
c'est le sait que c'est que ces
conneries même s'il est à 2 km je
t'emmène vote idi ben ouais je veux bien
parce arrive un truc sur cinq hectares
on assez polis un truc sublime dû
rentrer puis m'a intrigué bombe à la la
la la première machine bon bah c'est de
la merde
dans un premier trio première
transformation la crida mans à deux
kilomètres là bas tu vois c'est la
deuxième transformation ici elle
conditionnement arrive de vente une
motte de beurre
c'est incroyable a dit ferri 10 et
bombadil goûte donc il pourra tout pas
je comprends qu'on
lui donne à son pote de
ça quand même un goût de merde hein ah
bah oui
une histoire de deux bugs qui font un
concours est le premier qui réussit à
acheter un paquet de cigarettes le
paquet lui offert par l'autre dans
l'après-midi à à toi donc la mecque
traversé un mur entre dans le bureau de
tabac dia à la vendeuse bonjour
madame je vous la
a12
marlboro hadjaoui 10 euros il sort il
arrive en courant il fait 15 secondes à
toi loot arrive en courant il fait beau
jean madame je voudrais en a un paquet
de
deux
gitanes est lui fait oui avec ou sans
filtre à
100 sans filtre kaunas
hitler n'est pas mort ah merde voilà il
vit sur une île déserte voilà seuls
quelques nazis sa vie et ils viennent le
voir clair merci car elle en reprend
donc avril donc il clair n'est pas mort
il vit sur une île déserte et seulement
quelques nazis savent où il est donc ils
viennent le voir à une vingtaine en
faudrait revenir vraiment là c'est le
moment beaudry du non non
non non il dit j'ai merdé une première
fois maintenant je suis tranquille je
suis passé au travail je suis vieux
laissez moi tranquille il y vraiment non
ils reviennent à l'aide après ils sont
200 est vraiment fureur l'aurait bien
que vous reveniez il fait non je vous ai
déjà dit non je vais j'y vais pas voilà
je suis tranquille et c'est vrai mais
dit il ya urgence je m'en fous c'est
plus mon problème je suis vieux laissez
moi profiter d'après ils sont 2000 mec
salue tous à une fureur faut vraiment
revenir et dit non il y voyez bien
regarder années 2000 ils sont nombreux à
le demander partout en europe dans le
monde revenez
clé réfléchi fait
ok mais cette fois ci mais
chantal
celle d'une aide c'est le dîner de la
scène donc jésus les douze apôtres fille
et jésus dit comme je vous le dis l'un
de vous même trahir est ce toi pierre
jésus jamais et je suis la première
pierre de ton église ton premiers
fidèles jamais je leur ai dit je te
croit pierre et pourtant comme je vous
le dit l'un d'eux vous va me trahir
estoient thomas va pas du tout alors là
je dis non c'est vrai que j'ai été le
plus long mais je t'ai vu je crois en
toi je marche dans ta lumière je ferais
pas ça oui je te crois thomas et
pourtant comme je vous le dit l'un de
vous me trahir laisse toi jacques
jésus pas du tout je t'assure que non
vraiment je je crois en toi ne lance pas
moi je te croit jacques et pourtant
comme je vous le dis l'un de vous comme
traille est toi philippe taris fait un
nom non alors je suis comme les autres
mois ci alors pas du tout un fils de qui
ça peut être ben oui raul comme je vous
le dis l'un de vous même trahi
laisse-toi judas il est et sud est
ok bon
avec est chez lui devant un match de
foot j'ai oublié sa femme tu pourrais
m'en mener une bière avant que ça
commence alors la famille et prend une
bière à lui amène sa fuite après fille
chérie tu peux tu peuvent amener une
deuxième bien avant que ça commence
enfin fait d'accord prend une bière à
lui amène mec boit sa bière à ça car ils
font l'amour est une bien avant que ça
commence à fait tu peux pas bouger ton
qu un peu effet voilà ça commence
un mec sort de chez lui un matin pour
aller travailler il ya un type qui est
en bas de chez lui et qui en le voyant
pas sans lui du fait cocu qu'aucune
match mais pardon me suis fait cocu cocu
une formule soit pas bien mais que des
sent le mec le suit larry fait cocu cocu
le mec des 100 prend le métro le mec
monde dans la même rame que lui et de
loin lui fait cocu cocu mais que devient
dingue il ya jusqu'à son bureau comme ça
ibos le soir hiro descend à 18h le même
avec lada il fait ça cocu mais que
répond pas il fait cocu cocu cocu il y
en a de plus en plus fort le mec dans le
métro par le mexique en face cocu
mes craintes chez lui dit ah ce fameux
il ya un truc que je tue sa masse est
étrange et un mec qui m'a suivi toute la
journée qui m'a traité de con qu elle
fait et ba il faut que çà bizare t'as
rien à venir non monsieur était pas bien
non ça va dégénérer qui traite de cocu
dans la rue ça va être de ma fautif
énorme enfin un effet énorme mais ça va
j'aimerais enfin quand même souffert
mais que va se coucher lendemain matin
il se réveille il va bosser il ya le
même mec qui fait cocu comme et
rapporteur en plus
un juif marche dans la rue est un mec
qui lui tape sur l'épaule ils sont une
ivg à monchy-au-bois de l'argent
[Rires]